war in poverty and people talk about the
war but they're not talking about
poverty I don't I don't see any NSA
poverty I'm not talking about just to
poor people in the hood I'm talking
about middle-class poverty if there is a
middle-class left in America is dangling
on on it's dying of credit you know its
loans probably got a little stupid
adjustable rate mortgages people are
getting kicked out of houses all over
the place he Bush finally is trying to
step in thank God before I me because
people are losing their houses
but that that loss of house is a
reflection of the general economic
strategies which is people buy things
they don't need they buy it on credit
these kind of houses kind of bought on
credit is when you really look about it
a lot more they're buying a house on
credit and and the payment for the
credit gets higher and higher every year
so more more people in debt this is a
profound and fundamental problem in the
American economy it's not something to
just just because some Wall Street
stockbrokers are doing what does it mean
the economy is doing well when you look
at the the value of the dollar around
the world I just came back from England
you know you can building an ice cream
cone over there what's the dollar so
what is it saying this says these are
fundamental structural inequities and
problems and how our economy works and
none of these guys are going to address
that they're not going to address it
they're not dressing it now ever heard
hide nor hear about in any profound way
I need real systematically because
they're afraid to because they're
getting money from the same people who
run everything which is basically Wall
Street brokers and big business people
who are profiting off of our you know
and our problems are the small guys debt
debt is the biggest problem in this
country